the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I think it brings together I think some
of the administrators but also in fact
the last word of the text or liberation
my point of the week and the future so
this is our presentation on language
resistance in the liberation welcome to
the last day of class congratulations so
as a roadmap we're going to go through
first rethinking literacy the dialogue
the piece by ferry and Mikado get up
Macedo and then we're going to look at
the literacy in critical pedagogy piece
and then end with the MIT hati hati
initiatives okay so this is just a
little bit of a background on the
writers of the first two pieces both of
them are educators and critical pedagogy
and ones from Brazil and one is caper
day an American so in the first piece
fairy mentions the permit the main
premises of culture and I think that
these are really important to keep in
mind because this is a really
interesting and I think powerful way to
frame culture the first one is that
cultural cultural processes are
intimately connected with social
relations especially with class
relations and class formations with
sexual divisions with racial structuring
and social relations and with age
oppressions as a form of dependency got
it the second one culture involves power
and helps to produce asymmetries and the
abilities of individuals and social
groups to define and realize their needs
and third one culture is neither
autonomous nor an externally determined
field but obsess but a site of social
difficulties and struggles
those ideas are really important to keep
in mind because this paper also raises
this idea I know it is the social field
which is kind of the combination of all
of the beliefs myths aspirations hopes
of a book of a society of a culture and
so it's it includes things such as why
racial hierarchies exist
- why sexual divisions exist in like
what roles gender gender people play in
a society and it's really important to
keep that in mind because if you're able
to keep that in mind then you're able to
think critically about that and through
the critical process of engaging whether
you're able to change the social field
and so I think that that's important
because even though this paper raises a
lot of really powerful ideas it's still
not perfect so one of the quotes of this
paper is literacies oral dimension is
important even if it takes place in a
culture like that of the United States
whose memory is predominately written
not oral like that of Africa Africa is
notic and so something like that is also
part of the social field and would make
it into this paper because even though
ferry and Macedo are thinking critically
about this they are not engaging with a
full reality of cultural objectivity and
being subjects within that yeah the next
article Oliveri talks about the use of
and he first starts talking about how
the current traditional methods of
literacy how they tend to ignore the
importance of language in a person's
education and he bases a lot of his
theories on his experiences and from the
second quote he says that the sad
reality is that while education import
provides access to positions of
political and economic power for the
high echelon of African society it
screens out the majority of the masses
who failed to learn Portuguese well
enough to acquire the necessary literacy
skills for social economic and political
investment and you could definitely from
the way that he mentions this you could
definitely see a lot of like parallelism
between what's going on around the world
and eternity like in the United States
and you could you could definitely see
that the the one percent usually have
the most control over things and that
they usually tend to drive policies for
me but the fact is that when a person is
taught and during native language
detents you learn things better and
comprehend things faster and you go to
the next lake there's usually backlash
when it comes to different languages
taught in schools for example in the
u.s. people say that students should
learn how to speak standard American
English but when it comes to providing
these sort of opportunities to minority
group so I guess for instance like
students of color there's usually some
regional tensions that develop that that
made minority students feel inferior
for example there was an article
mentioned like recently in like March of
2017 that talked about a robotics team
diversity that recently had won the
challenge and the fact that after they
had won students but I guess people in
the crowd started screaming at them and
telling them to go back to Mexico and so
this form of like demeaning commentary
tends to drive the dropout rate so
minority groups and all this tends to
contribute to like the prison sorry the
school to Prison Pipeline has
seen the infographic it definitely gives
a lot of percentages on that talked
about this sort of issue in the bottom
when he says that 16% of all males in
state and federal prison they do not
have a high school diploma and this
sense to me gives the statistics on
students cooking and all of this 10th
that tends to stem from the fact that
minority students do not have the same
access to education as you think our
society and from personal experience I
can definitely relate to this I went to
school about like an hour and a half for
my house and I definitely did have a lot
of like good role models growing up but
there were definitely and students
around my neighborhood that didn't that
definitely didn't have the same access
to the same opportunities that I did
some of them did drop out to serving
others worried big gangs around my
neighborhood and you could definitely
these are definitely getting better but
things could definitely be improved from
any medicine that emancipatory literacy
approach which is what Paula Ferry
mentions yeah so in a monetary literacy
this involves using the language of the
people rather than the need to teach
students to accept their experiences and
their culture and this moves from the
world of objectivity to the world of
subjectivity where individuals learn to
accept themselves for who they are
rather than feel like they're a victim
of society and pollen fury does mention
that achieving emancipatory illiteracy
is hard but it's not impossible and now
and so learning was talked about a few
examples of how this is being used today
so considering specifically in the case
of Haiti which Michelle works a lot on
but that mighty Haiti initiative
virtually all of the schooling in both K
through 12 education and then
higher education is done in French and
not in Creole but the problem is that
most people only speak Creole fluently
so like 95 percent or so and very few
people speak French fluently at all so
when you go through school and
everything is in a language that you
don't understand how are you supposed to
be able to actually get any of the
education get any of the social
engagement especially if children are
punished for speaking Creole in school
and they like can't interact with each
other it can't ask questions can't
gather any of the information that's
coming at them so it's based on this
false belief and really outdated belief
about the hierarchy of languages about
which languages are created or are
younger or anything like that and that
Creole isn't developed enough to be able
to to be used for technical language for
STEM education to have anything
translated into Creole and part of that
is saying that like Creole isn't
widespread enough even though Creole has
almost 10 million speakers finnish has
only about 5.5 million speakers and yet
in finland all of the education is done
in finnish and people have studies have
found that in finland kids are much
better much better equipped to be able
to learn a second language and to go
into higher education and gather gather
all of these like technical studies
because all of their education is done
in finnish and over i AP i was doing
misty GTL in the Catalunya region in
Spain and there
Catalan also has a little under ten
million speakers but in Catalunya all of
the education is in Catalan which made
it difficult for me as like a Spanish
speaker like not even fluent but trying
to speak Spanish speaker to be able to
teach the students but they had such a
better experience with all of their
textbooks in Catalan all of their
computer software so I was trying to
teach them Inkscape and [ __ ] but
everything was in Catalan and I just
couldn't understand like even how to
open a window um so they taught me a lot
about this
they all of them speak Catalan and
Spanish and English and then they can
like learn German or French on the side
as well so all of them because their
initial education K through 12 and then
higher education if they want it to be
is in Catalan then they can learn all of
these other things just as well as we do
like in English with it which is mostly
our one and kind of only language in the
United States yeah so that was my
experience and what a school that is
like a really good model in Haiti is the
lkm school I didn't know how to
pronounce it in Creole so South cam it's
a k310 school in a rural part on an
island of Haiti and their education is
starting to be in this model of all
Creole education trying to teach all of
these subjects all of the technical
terms in Creole and the students are
learning much better than the rest of
the students in Haiti who's schooling is
at French and who only 10% graduate from
high school
so the linguistic apartheid part of this
is that when you teach somebody in a
language they don't understand you
prevent them from being able to move
into different socio-economic classes to
attain the education and the success
that they should be able to and this all
leads to a mighty Haiti initiative that
we shall started here between MIT and
all the Haitian education systems so a
couple of their main points are to teach
educators in Haiti that teaching and
creole is perfectly fine that it is
actually better for the students that it
gives them more opportunities and that
stem and technical subjects can be
taught in Creole so a lot of the worries
or concerns are that like Creole doesn't
have words for these languages we didn't
have words for a computer either up
until when they were created a lot of
other languages borrow words from other
languages so I learned Japanese and in
Japanese there's this lovely thing
called katakana where you just grab
where it's your mother language so if
you don't know how to pronounce it you
kind of like make it sound like it and
oftentimes it
is what has been borrowed so for example
bread is pun from German and all of
these other languages have words
borrowed from other languages and that's
what globalization does so the same
thing should be able to happen with
Creole and stem learning and the really
good results of this or that they
affirmed students cultures and
backgrounds and their own upbringing and
how the society actually works as
opposed to a colonial oppressive society
and equalize the students being able to
have more social mobility and to attain
what they want and what they should be
able to so to kind of tie this back to
what we can do to stay woke with regards
to literacy I think it's important to
remember that language is a mediating
force of knowledge but it is also
knowledge itself and so one approach is
for groups to kind of come together and
create a language that describes their
experience amongst themselves and then
to share that language and to share that
experience in their own in their own
language and I think that that is one
way that we can start breaking away from
the kind of putting standard English on
a pedestal and can also kind of validate
other discourses and other ways of being
and other just languages that kind of
already exists in the US and across the
world
questions okay how have our
understandings of literacy evolved in
response to the internet unprecedented
global integration and increased
pressure to preserve human rights for
example what does it mean that schools
repress the development of subjectivity
but due largely ensure literacy
how can modern notions of literacy
evolved to address phenomena such as the
prolific proliferation of fake news so
if we're moving past literacy as just
the idea of being able to read and we
are entering this new kind of this new
waving that's largely pushed by the
Internet and the influence of Technology
on the way we live literacy is coming to
being a more critical approach to life
in the sense that fake news is a thing
you know and it's actually quite hard to
distinguish what news is really what
news is fake and the ability to do that
having that critical lens is maybe the
next evolution of literacy so any ideas
that I guess is the question but
something that I think is kind of
hilarious about like integration the
Internet is that I think it
simultaneously making us more literate
and less literate so like or like
crushing me to be more literate so
pressuring you to be more literate now
there's a bunch of sources that you can
read and like now you can be more
educated it's all open to the public you
have a computer and then there's also
like the pressure to speak English
properly based off either you know like
this one viral videos old grandma's
screaming at this
I hop because she was paying in Spanish
or something like that so like it puts
pressure on you to speak English
correctly and then meanwhile because of
like things like Facebook and like any
social media people like don't speak
correctly like typing like you know
abbreviations and stuff that's
acceptable in tax but like meanwhile
we're saying like you should speak
English properly so it's kind of a weird
dichotomy I'm interested in the age
implications of what you just said kind
of a lining kind of a critique towards
the use of different varieties of
English with older generations and the
use of non-standard varieties of English
with younger donations I'm interested in
that yeah I think I mean I guess like so
like there's a grandma that I know
that's on Facebook and like she like
make sure it's to like type everything
out including punctuation like her
facebook posts are longer and like
they're more like here's a card I think
today where is like my facebook a I'm
just sharing things but B if I really
think it's probably which so I think it
does depend on like your age group but
also like going back to the original
point of like you know that grandma's
screaming at the Hispanic woman and like
an IHOP like it's not just like an older
woman screaming because you know she's
more illiterate like there's also like
kids who like think like oh you have to
speak English up here so like they're
you still is that weirdness between like
how like older people like act on
facebook and stuff like that but I still
think like the point of you know
pressuring people is regardless of age
I think because I'm going to be talking
about language which is dialects in this
class I would kind of risk saying that
we're kind of creating a new language
because of the internet with like all
the abbreviations and things and the way
push for speed and everything like that
so I think the reason that old
generations don't use it as question
because it I used to it and then like
that differently frame of reference and
they just haven't like learned this new
dialect that we're starting to use so I
think that it's a good thing in a sense
but a lot of people who want that
standard American English are going to
be pushing us to go back to that as
opposed to using the Internet in English
the goys parts like our Cajun taste in
literacy because of the internet like I
didn't know that the onion was satire at
first I said look at the end it existed
and then I found I realized that it was
satire I think step new ones like that
is something that you miss especially
with the internet because you can't
really express sarcasm very clearly over
just plain text I think that's something
that we're
but I think that he said we talked about
the onion I think that shows like that
show that
I want to bounce up what you rich and he
said like with like it's not a bad thing
that we're tending my language I cream
it like dimension do you think like
there are certain rules like the way we
type and laid there like illiterate like
like for instance punctuating substances
with like lol oh haha
I didn't realize my question is so
knowing now that people grow up in a
type of leaders into whether it's a
tradition or emancipatory what are the
pros and cons of your type of literacy
and explain the moon why we should move
either towards or away from it from an
emancipatory leaders
I mean if it's helping people learn I
don't see Adama
especially because it's kind of
broadening their worldview a a couple of
presentations ago there were the
students who are playing jeopardy with
AE and that was kind of like broadening
their worldview like even if you went to
the school and didn't speak any you are
learning about a new language that you
weren't familiar with and so they were
able to do this through them inspiratory
literacy what the
so kind of just play devil's advocate a
little bit I think I guess one of the
dangers of emancipatory
that receipt might be kind of this non
standardization like with initiatives
like common core things like that we
kind of have an educational system that
setup so that everybody's kind of put on
the same level to some extent like
everybody has that same kind of baseline
education but like with emancipatory
literacy i think you're gonna find my
educational programs are geared towards
a specific like cultural norms and
things that nature related to whatever
population and targets so I wonder if
that could potentially produce a system
in which certain students even though
they're receiving an education eyes
appeared towards them it's objectively
not that same quality of students who
are would seem like more of a
traditional approach I want to push back
on that just a little bit because I
think that the standardized approach to
education is the approach that's been
taken with the you know teach for test
approach and it's failed it's been
failing for a while now and I think that
a lot of people in education policy and
even just teachers are recognizing that
now and I think that education
emancipatory literacy gives us an
interesting lens to think about how to
educate people so that they can learn
and I think maybe another place we can
start kind of investing energy is
thinking of ways in society that we can
value those different ways of knowing
and being and learning so that it's not
just uh you went to college so you
deserve to be paid a lot of money kind
of thing and it's uh oh you can you know
build the table from scratch how do you
get paid to do that
I think MIT is way far the tradition MIT
is the alt-right of traditional
literature I just think that there are I
think that the the immense pressure that
falls on students just on students
physical bodies is definitely a symptom
of a larger problem and for me the fact
that that symptom is not enough of an
impedance to change is heartbreaking
because I think that I did I didn't I
didn't come to college expecting it to
be the four best four years of my life
but I didn't come here also expecting to
this suffering I think that there's
definitely got to be a way where I can
can bloom can reach my best potential
and I love learning I love like I loved
school you know and the fact that I yeah
I have just kept running up against the
institution I think as a creative person
has made me kind of step back and think
again about events but sorry literacy
and how I can do that
after given what you just said I want
you to issue it to be mit president what
would you change what how would you make
it better
more individually keeping in mind that
maybe a certain cause I just reach in
terms of a chemist how would you do that
how would you how would you advise the
ministration I think the very first
thing I would do is have people who are
more interested in research and not be
professors so the ones who are
interested in research should be doing
research full-time and the people who
are interested in teaching should teach
because I think that that gives like a
that gives people more impetus to just
like connect with their students and
actually get to know them and I think in
that kind of environment you would
foster like a safer healthier
environment for learning whereas if you
have a professor who is more interested
in like winning the Nobel Prize like
what are you like what do you do coming
up against that I also would have MIT
think very very hard about where the
funding is coming from what it's going
to and how that kind of fits in a global
system where MIT as an institution fits
in the global system as kind of
not only an institution that does propel
you to a higher class but kind of does
that at the expense of a lot of other
people and systems across the globe even
if it's not directly in the area so I
think that being more critical and
intentional about our values and also
maybe adding soul to the end of that the
end of that of motto the last question
is from your personal experiences or
what you've seen or read about how do
you think we can improve students
experiences and confidence through
intentional language use in schools like
what mottos do you think are working or
would work but it struggles to secure
funding because it also doesn't follow a
standardized Canadian curriculum in fact
the community has sort of decolonized
the curriculum and they teach history
for instance not Canadian history they
teach Mohawk history and it's been
really affirming for children in the
community especially a community that
has its own struggles with language
preservation and revitalization and
passing on the language to continue
generations especially after a history
of residential schooling that you know
main aim was a cultural and linguistic
genocide of these people so this is a
great model but it's funded entirely by
a community
razors and every year struggles with
staying open and it's never certain that
it'll be there in the next school year
but it seems to have had a really really
positive impact on the Mohawk community
in Canada and so programs like that I
think need to now be funded and that
that involves challenging our our
federal and local requirements not for
funding and to do that we need to
interrogate what value there is in the
curricula we have standardized and why
that is considered objectively like the
standard that should impart the best
learning experience upon students
go ahead Colleen so bouncing up that and
seems like we get to like ensuring the
anything where the next platitudinous is
inculcated in this like standard
spherical goes into society and then way
perpetuates a static critical back on V
M students so I'm curious about if
anyone has thoughts about how you could
make knowledge about because one of the
main hurdle is see the like instituting
there's like entire continuation
strictly chief about how the story of
America's history has been with Garvey
native and genocide slavery and the for
lack of ever mean that is and best
estimate how do you make people aware of
that on a level that they can see those
things playing out to pay and work to
interior that curriculum especially
they're coming from a background where
like racism talk about center because
it's an uncomfortable topic or if
they're just like haven't heard about
her manipulative clothes on to the where
do you learn to interrogate your own
beliefs and I feel like that's hard to
find and I came to this class was like a
key part of that for me and I don't know
if that was because I got started up or
just like I happened to stumble upon a
place where I learned a Tara gave my
beliefs but this isn't that a permit for
themselves but I don't really have an
answer for how we get choked with a
value of interrogating kovalyonok how
much more enriched your life is gonna be
like you're just knocking off of that
economy and possibly how do we have
conversations with people who don't want
to have this conversation and I think
like the only way for them to figure out
further to target yourselves but like
most those people won't
so like finding ways to tear it like to
make them a target insult I think is it
any like a common problem like
throughout history and like
unfortunately I don't know if I
personally have a group like solution
for that but I think like more
opportunities like this I mean obviously
like you mentioned this before like the
people who are taking this class we're
not really diversified in thought right
like we all saw this class out mostly so
I don't know how you can get someone who
doesn't want to tarry saucily it was
doing like this so maybe like mandating
something like this where you have to go
to like a black history class or a
Native American history class or like
whatever might force people to search
yeah I almost think it might be better
to not have a separate classroom this is
your you know well-rounded miss class
but this is when we're gonna learn about
the others but to integrate what you
would learn in a specific black history
class into the general curriculum which
of course is harder and but I do think
would require the same amount of
conversations and connections and
negotiations as making a requirement you
know of a separate class but I think
that a better approach that might be
more palatable and have more positive
effects would be just turned up
integration decolonizing the courage I
told you I was gonna say I totally agree
with Dana I think that um losing my
train of thought I totally agree with
Dana because I think that the history
will speak for itself I think that
history is like if you know they pulled
a full history unlike the United States
for example it's pretty it's pretty
terrible and I think that you do need to
know the whole history and also need to
get the alternative sides and have those
be like integrated into the curriculum I
also was interested in I'm thinking
about like entry points into these
conversations in like ways that like art
and humor can function as entry points
in the conversations I've been having
this conversation with a friend of mine
of how like humor for example gives us a
way to kind of express some of these
things that are more taboo and kind of
laughed them off and kind of like
integrate them as opposed to everyone
shutting them and people feeling bobbled
so I am interested about like humor and
art specifically as entry points into
these conversations
Nina I think what she'll say no way
answers the concern that should be
expressed right so the good should be
put it as is isn't dual Troy that's
really do people do that right so if
then ask is right right should be what
could imagine I mean every class like
very good twist
critical math class chemistry class or
being attention to those issues in
Friday's roaming for that even even if
you take it simple photographic one can
even think about what kind of choice is
going into making a camera and actually
I have friends were photographers and
they picked me that I feel most cameras
were gonna deal to think because of
black people so even there was a white
of the record you fact that mean takes a
picture with his regular Canon of the
white person becomes much better in wind
exit of the factors of why because the
lenses are defined with with the
dominant gaze of the white subject all
right so in had to tweak it camera to
make it take good pictures of black
people so even there even in clean
physics they should be a way to
interrogate the the curriculum why
internet in familial event a couple so
in a way it could be both you could both
have the military PTSD within the
correct codes more recently and going
back to the last point in American
history in biology value to include text
like I mentioned earlier is to conduct
and the miss nature of man
which was it's lots of difficult issues
of ecology how we met hands were
measures to show that limited
intelligence for example for many years
when you were coming in here to address
and they will take a picture naked and
they would look at a picture to decide
what kind of student you will become mr.
physical traits like of the attention of
the most out of what was called and
phenology you know which is the measure
so there is plenty plenty of room to
integrate within I I want to express the
fact that to do such a thing is not just
to include all of the the hushed
historical abuses that we glossed over
in our current like curricula but it's
also to to acknowledge the good that we
have overlooked so discoveries and
innovations that other people who are
not quote-unquote Western and who are
not an Anglo American have made and
contributed to the fields of science and
history and literature so not only to
recognize you know visa star goal evils
but also rather grand positive impacts
that others have had okay
you